wirkt begehen die sendung mit einer
anderen meldung seite wochen suchte die
polizei den vergewaltiger von
kleinmachnow ein serientäter
jetzt ist er endlich gefasst das
schockierende erst gestern soll wieder
eine frau in der nähe von potsdam
vergewaltigt haben
kurz darauf wurde er festgenommen
großeinsatz der berliner polizei in
einem wohngebiet in wannsee
hier nimmt die polizei am dienstagabend
den 30 jährigen fest immer wieder soll
er sich in den letzten wochen an frauen
vergangen haben zuletzt am tag der
festnahme nach derzeitigen erkenntnissen
handele es sich um die gesuchten
serientäter erklärte die berliner
generalstaatsanwaltschaft bei twitter
zuletzt hatte der serien vergewaltiger
offenbar am dienstagmorgen zugeschlagen
zwischen babelsberg und drei linden
vergewaltigte ein mann eine junge frau
nach dem joggen
nach ersten erkenntnissen der polizei
soll der täter die frau angesprochen und
nach dem weg gefragt haben kurz darauf
soll er sie dann überwältigt und
vergewaltigt haben
dann flüchtete er offenbar mit einem
fahrrad gegen mittag fehlt das opfer
einer passantin auf die frau stand
offenbar unter schock und gab an
vergewaltigt worden zu sein
sie kam später in ein krankenhaus die
polizei setzte daraufhin einen
hubschrauber eine drohne sowie mehrere
fährtenhunde 1
auch werde der bundespolizei waren
entlang der möglichen fluchtwege im
einsatz
gegen 19 uhr soll dann ein anwohner in
berlin-wannsee gesehen haben wie ein
mann in eine grundstückseinfahrt gerannt
sei anwohner gaben an dass der mann
genauso ausgesehen habe
wie der gesuchte auf dem phantombild auf
dem grundstück wird der verdächtige dann
festgenommen weitere details will die
polizei am mittwoch bekannt geben
und live aus berlin ist mir jetzt bild
reporter matthias becker zugeschaltet
guten morgen matthias der täter wurde
jetzt endlich gefasst er hat erst
gestern als gestern soll er wieder eine
frau vergewaltigt haben und das obwohl
die ganze zeit öffentlich nach ihm
gefahndet wurde
was weiß man über den täter ja also der
täter galt als top fahndung in berlin
und in brandenburg
er hat sich genau das grenzgebiet
zwischen potsdam kleinmachnow und
zehlendorf ausgesucht dass er alles im
südwesten der stadt einer feiner
wohngegend eine wohngegend aber auch die
grüne lunge genannt ein gebiet das für
für freizeitsportler und sogar besonders
begehrt und beliebt ist der mann ist 30
jahre er soll serbe sein und er war so
brandgefährlich weil er jede handlung
jede steuerungsfähigkeit verloren hat er
hat nahezu fast täglich ist der durch
streifzüge und und soll mutmaßlich acht
frauen überfallen massiv vergewaltigt
oder es versucht haben und was passiert
jetzt mit dem täter er ist nach der
festnahme gestern gleich nach potsdam in
die polizeizentrale gekommen wurde dort
bestimmt das erst einmal versucht zu
vernehmen wenn er bereit war überhaupt
etwas zu der sache zu sagen jetzt ist
aber vorrangig
man könnte möglicherweise im
genitalbereich verletzt sein
vielleicht womöglich hat sich ein opfer
derart stark gewehrt dass er verletzt
ist er kommt aber auf jeden fall jetzt
erstmal in ein krankenhaus er muss
untersucht werden auf krankheiten auf
hepatitis auf andere
geschlechtskrankheiten oder aber auch
aids all das sind ja für die opfer die
frauen jetzt fehlende stunden
was hat der mann ungeschützter
eigentlich angestellt und welche strafe
droht diesen serien vergewaltiger jetzt
ja auch da haben wir immer das leidliche
thema das erstmal gutachten diesen man
sich anschauen lassen und dann wird man
gucken um wen handelt es sich war ja
überhaupt möglich dass er die das
unrecht seiner tat einsehen konnte
welche kindheit hat er gehabt zpp
ansonsten ein serien vergewaltiger
dieser art muss natürlich mit
mehrjährigen freiheitsstrafen rechnen
oder aber er ist nicht er hatte keine
kontrolle mehr über sein leben und kommt
deswegen einen sogenannten
maßregelvollzug ein krankenhaus für
straftäter welt reporter matthias becker
vielen dank für deine information